so welcome again we got off to a good
start last night with our fiery talk
fine talk by Lou Dobbs he pulls no
punches as usual and I think he set the
stage for us for our panel this morning
on globalization the pros and cons of
globalization to discuss this topic much
in the news we have assembled a
distinguished panel and what I'd like to
do is introduce all three of them right
now and then they will take the podium
one at a time
clyde Presta wits is the founder and
president of the economic strategy
institute he holds a BA from Swarthmore
College an MA from the east-west Center
of the University of Hawaii and an MBA
from the Wharton Graduate School of
Business
he served as counselor to the Secretary
of Commerce in the Reagan administration
where he headed us negotiations with a
number of foreign countries and he was a
leader of the first u.s. trade mission
to China he writes for several
publications including fortune Foreign
Affairs and The Straits Times he is the
author of several books including the
betrayal of American prosperity
free-market delusions America's decline
and how we must compete in the post
dollar era
Daniel Griswold sitting here to my right
is senior research fellow and
co-director of the program and the
American economy and globalization at
the Mercatus Center at George Mason
University he holds a bachelor's degree
in journalism from the University of
Wisconsin at Madison and a master's in
the politics of the world economy from
the London School of Economics and
political science he has previously
served as president of the National
Association of foreign trade zones and
as director of trade and immigration
studies for the Cato Institute he has
testified before various congressional
committees and he is the author of
numerous studies and articles he is also
the author of the
mad about trade why Main Street America
should embrace globalization and lastly
but not least Jeff ferry sitting here to
my left is research director at the
Coalition for a prosperous America where
his research and analysis focuses on
trade and industrial policies and the
promotion of American economic growth he
has degrees in economics from Harvard in
the London School of Economics and
political science he has extensive
experience as an economist a financial
and Technology journalist and a
technology executive he has written for
numerous publications including the
Washington Post and Forbes magazine and
also for Bloomberg News in addition he
has produced documentaries on business
for the BBC and other British television
broadcasters he is the author of the
book the British Renaissance and with
that since we are still missing mr.
presto it's I will ask Dan Griswold to
speak first
dan
[Applause]
thank thank you Tim and Thank You
Hillsdale College for sponsoring this
this economic forum this free market for
him I'm a great fan of Hillsdale College
and its service not only to its students
but to America and the cost of Liberty
over the years and and it's great to be
in Texas here in Texas I have a few
things in common with people in Texas a
love of good barbecue and and free
enterprise
I admire the resiliency of the people in
in the state whether it's two wild
swings in the price of oil or hurricanes
that drop 50 inches of rain and what a
great place to talk about free trade and
globalization as in so many other areas
Texas is number one in states in terms
of international trade in exports to the
rest of the world more than 1 million
jobs in Texas depend directly on
exporting to other countries and the
number one market for exports from Texas
is Mexico whether it's natural gas going
through new pipelines beef cotton
semiconductors airplanes Mexico is your
number one market and another half
million Texans work for foreign owned
affiliates in Texas which is another
area of globalization you're going to
hear a lot about globalization how to
define it I see it as basically the the
increasingly free movement of goods
services capital people across
international borders and despite what
you hear from some people globalization
is not a top-down phenomenon it's what
happens when people in America and
around the world are left free by their
governments to do business with one
another it's spontaneous order it's what
Adam Smith called the natural system of
Liberty
free trade means more competition to
provide you and me with goods and
services that make our lives better to
provide those at lower cost more variety
better quality think of automobiles
shoes clothing food electronics and the
greatest proportional benefits go to low
income households single parents who
spend a higher share of their budget on
tradable items like clothing footwear
and food and the savings that we realize
from lower priced imports means we have
more to spend on domestically provided
goods and services like education
entertainment housing eating out and
imports are critical to American
producers who utilize global supply
chains more than half of what we import
each year to the United States are not
things for consumption but for
production capital goods raw materials
intermediate components if American
companies can source globally for their
inputs that leads to lower priced final
products more competitive products in
domestic and foreign markets
and of course free trade means lower
barriers around the world to US exports
80% of the world's spending power 95% of
the world's people live outside the
United States American companies need to
sell in global markets if they are going
to survive and thrive in the 21st
century
let me just tackle a couple of myths
that I think you'll hear a little bit
about this morning it's a myth that
trade has somehow decimated our
manufacturing base America remains an
industrial and manufacturing powerhouse
in the global economy our manufacturing
sector year after year
produces more than two trillion dollars
in value-added it's near a record high
real manufacturing output in the last 25
years is up more than 40% we are leading
or among the world's leaders in
manufacturing civilian aircraft
appliances motor vehicles micro
processors chemicals pharmaceuticals
petroleum refined petroleum products of
which Texas is a leader and despite what
you might hear about the beleaguered
domestic steel industry we remain the
world's fourth largest steel producer
you'll also hear about jobs and trade
job losses in manufacturing are not
primarily because of trade but because
of technology a recent study from Ball
State University looked at the years
2000 to 2010 and in that decade we lost
a net 5.6 million manufacturing jobs but
they found that 85% of those job losses
we're not from trade but from
productivity gains filled by technology
and and innovation the right response to
job losses is not to raise trade
barriers it's to prepare ourselves and
our children for the jobs that are being
created in our modern economy to improve
education retraining labor markets
mobility we need to prepare our
workforce for the jobs of today and
tomorrow not try to bring back the jobs
of yesterday trade agreements have
proven to be the most effective way to
reduce barriers to US exports around the
world they've kept trade barriers down
even in difficult times they've helped
us avoid the destructive trade wars that
we suffered in the 1930s
and here's where I have to take a polite
issue with our speaker last night one of
our most successful trade deals is the
North American Free Trade Agreement
[Applause]
withdrawing from NAFTA would be a
colossal blunder for the state of Texas
and the nation as a whole by every
reasonable measure NAFTA has been a
success since its passage two-way trade
among the NAFTA countries the United
States Canada and Mexico has more than
tripled to over a trillion dollars
Canada and Mexico are now our top two
export markets buying 34 percent of US
exports NAFTA has delivered the level
playing field that our politicians
always tell us they want before NAFTA
Mexico had much higher tariffs on US
exports going to Mexico than we had on
Mexican imports coming into the United
States NAFTA has reduced duties in all
directions to zero what could be more
fair than that
as a result North American production
and capital markets are highly
integrated making the automobile sector
and others very competitive in global
markets I agree with your Texas
controller who said recently the biggest
loser in tearing up NAFTA and throwing
it in the trash really would be Texas
because we are an export state in the
past 30 years we've entered free trade
agreements with 20 countries in a big
study that was released last summer the
US International Trade Commission that's
a quasi independent trade body in in
Washington they studied those agreements
and the economic effect they've had on
the US economy and here was their
conclusion those agreements have
increased two-way trade with
tá partner countries and goods and
services by 26% over what it would be
otherwise they have boosted us economic
output and employment they've delivered
higher real wages and lower prices and
more product variety for millions of
American households and they've actually
increased our ability to collect on
intellectual property from abroad by 10
billion dollars a year we're collecting
10 billion dollars or more a year
because of trade agreements well in
contrast to the blessings of free trade
government protection through higher
trade barriers is really just another
form of central planning it's the
government intervening in the economy to
stifle competition it's a conspiracy to
raise prices at the expense of the
majority of American citizens protection
has left in its wake
coddled industries and political
cronyism as one economist Doug Irwin
said in The Wall Street Journal recently
protectionism isn't draining the swamp
it it created the swamp in part through
all the lobbying for special protection
protection is not about America first
it's about sticking it to certain groups
of Americans for the benefit of other
smaller groups of politically connected
producers and leaving our nation as a
result weaker and poorer a textbook case
for what's wrong with us protection is
the u.s. steel industry decade after
decade the steel industry has sought
special protection from Washington
against its foreign competition now the
Trump administration is actually
weighing broad tariffs on imported steel
all in the name of national security
I think that would also be a huge
mistake
the Trump administration blames the woes
of the steel industry that I think are
exaggerated they blame them on imports
and the problems with manufacturing
generally on imports which we've seen
isn't the case the decline of jobs in
the steel industry when you look at it
has nothing to do with imports the
primary driver of declining employment
in the steel industry is soaring
productivity which is a good thing I was
taught when I studied economics fueled
by automation and changing steel
production methods and also the
declining demand for steel in our more
high-tech 21st century economy consider
the fact that if you go back to the
1970s and I remember the 1970s u.s.
steel consumption per capita was almost
double what it is today back in the 70s
on average Americans consumed about 1400
pounds of Steel a year today that's down
to 741 pounds so despite the growth of
our economy in our population we're
actually consuming less steel as a
nation today than we were in the 1970s
and imports back then made up about 20%
of our consumption it's 21 percent today
so that really hasn't changed meanwhile
the productivity of the domestic cieth
steel industry has really gone through
the roof and this is a great story for
the steel industry back in the 1970s it
took about ten man hours to produce a
ton of steel today it takes less than
two man hours and at some of the newer
mini mills it takes less than a man hour
to produce a ton of steel lower demand
lower overall demand rising productivity
it's kind of simple math it guarantees
that there will be fewer jobs
significantly fewer jobs in the industry
that's why imposing duties on imported
steel will do nothing nothing to bring
back jobs to Youngstown Ohio and other
steel producing areas imposing duties on
imported steel will actually weaken the
US manufacturing base why because there
are a lot more companies and workers who
depend on imported steel as an input to
their production process then actually
make steel the steel industry itself in
America today actually employs only
about a hundred and forty thousand
workers but if you look at steel
consuming industries they employ more
than six million American workers so for
every job that's supposedly saved or
protected in the steel industry by
higher tariffs there are 40 jobs of our
fellow Americans who are put at risk by
those hardest-hit would be the
construction industry and the automobile
industry together they consume about
two-thirds of the steel in the United
States each year other key industries
that consume steel are machinery and
equipment energy and appliances higher
steel prices because of tariffs would
drive up the cost of domestic steel
we've become a kind of island of high
steel prices in the global economy that
would raise the price of production the
cost of production and the final price
of their goods for these industries
reducing sales at home and abroad and of
course reduced sales would translate
into destroying more jobs actually
destroying more jobs in the steel using
industries and they would protect in the
steel industry itself and steel tariffs
would jeopardize US exports if the
United States wraps itself in the flag
of national security to protect its
domestic steel industry other countries
are going to do the same they're going
to raise tariffs not just on u.s. steel
but on a broad range of goods tariffs
will go up
against key American exports from
computers to soybeans disrupting even
more US jobs you know we had a
protectionist experiment in this country
and some some people actually look back
kind of fondly on that era I wasn't
around then but my my my parents were
America's protectionist experiment
reached a kind of crescendo in 1930 with
the passage of the smoot-hawley Tariff
Act the bill raised duties on thousands
of items manufactured goods agricultural
commodities the results of the bill were
disastrous instead of reviving domestic
industry the bill spurred retaliatory
tariffs from our major trading partners
including Canada both US exports and
imports plummeted in the wake of
smoot-hawley now smoot-hawley didn't
cause the Great Depression but it didn't
alleviate it either
in fact it deepened and prolonged the
Great Depression and the suffering of
the American people after World War two
in a bipartisan way American leaders
made a monumental decision to turn away
from America first inward-looking
protectionism of the 1930s and to engage
and lead in the global economy to set a
good example to sign international
agreements starting with a general
agreement on tariffs and trade on
through the World Trade Organization and
various regional and bilateral
agreements in the seven decades since
then in our postable our post-war trade
policy has delivered competition
innovation better paying jobs and more
freedom for the American people but
beyond our borders it has also helped in
and and we need to care about this just
as people and it has humanitarians it
has helped to lift
hundreds of millions of people out of
poverty in fact in the world today the
number of people living in absolute
poverty according to the World Bank has
fallen in the last 25 years by 1 billion
people 1 billion fewer people living in
absolute poverty and enjoying something
like the middle class lives that we all
take for granted there's a number of
reasons behind that but one of the
primary reasons is the spread of
globalization of global capitalism of
which we've have played a role and and
this was a motivation of Secretary of
State Cordell Hull under FDR who was an
architect of our move towards freer
trade it has helped to preserve the
peace among the Western powers after two
devastating world wars free trade and
globalization have made America stronger
and more prosperous while helping to
create a more hospitable world in our
national interest thank you
[Applause]
honey I'm gonna start with a parable a
story it seems that there was a hiker
and he had had was arrested for killing
and eating a California condor a condors
are protected Birds you're not supposed
to kill them you're not supposed to eat
them and so eventually this hiker was
brought to court and the prosecutor
threw the book at him it was open and
shut it appeared because the guy had
killed and eaten the Condor and he
admitted they had he killed and eaten
the Condor so the prosecutor asked for
the maximum sentence life imprisonment
and before issuing the sentence the
judge turned to the hiker and he said
you know looks pretty bad for you but do
you have anything to 2nd hiker says yeah
I do judge he said look it was like this
there were extenuating circumstances
said you know I had been hiking for
three days and three nights without food
or water I was getting to the point of
starvation and I happen to see this bird
sitting on a rock I picked up a stone
through it killed it ate it and then I
walked for three more days and three
more nights without food or water before
reaching civilization if I hasn't killed
that bird I wouldn't be here today to
tell the story judge said well you know
those really were unusual circumstances
and in light of those circumstances
he would issue a suspended sentence so
the judge it is mounted against the
block and said the court dismissed and
everyone began to leave the courtroom
the hiker began to leave but just as the
hiker was about to leave the room the
judge called to him and he said by the
way what did that condor taste like and
a hiker paused for a moment he said mmm
tell you this judge it was kind of
between a spotted owl so you know
clearly the the judge and the jury
excuse me the jury and Iker had a
different concept of how the law was
supposed to be applied and how it was
being applied and so let me take a
moment to explain similarity between the
Condor and the eating a hiker in our
situation today globalization is nothing
new it's been around for essentially the
span of human existence Christopher
Columbus whose statues many cities are
now trying to take down was in fact a
great globe list discovered the new
world but Asia or the Americas and
Europe together and led to a huge global
round of shrinking the globe the British
Empire of the late 18th and 19th
centuries was a machine of globalization
creation of colonies Australia the
colonization of India Africa of the
Americas all tied together in the
British Empire created of course the
enormous international flows of trade
indeed it was the Boston Tea Party was a
protest against some aspects of
globalization under the British Empire
19th century was really a century of
globalization interestingly the United
States participated in a half way manner
we exported indeed in the nineteenth
century the u.s. active very much as
China is acting today it protected its
domestic markets the the US was a
protectionist mercantilist economy
throughout most of the 19th century
really until the end of World War two
Abraham Lincoln has been called the
great Emancipator but you could call him
the great protector he raised American
tariffs higher than they had ever been
in the 1860s by the beginning of the
First World War the world's economy was
more globalized more integrated than it
would be again for almost a hundred
years the indeed the globalization of
the early nineteen hundred's was
fascinating you didn't need a passport
to travel you didn't have to worry about
exchange rates Gould was was the world's
money and indeed goods and services flow
particularly investment well
matically in the early 20th century in
1912 Norman Angell
famous British author wrote a book
called the grand illusion and the
argument of the book was that the major
countries were so integrated UK France
Germany were all each other's major
trading partners and the argument was
that they were so integrated that war
would be unthinkable
well of course in 1914 we found that war
was not unthinkable and as I said the
world would not reach the level of 1914
globalization until about 1994 the u.s.
as I said was a protectionist
mercantilist
power you just got rich as a
mercantilist protectionist economy but
at the end of World War two we faced the
situation in which the rest of the world
was in ruins and the US was competitive
in virtually every industry and partly
in order to enable world economic
recovery and partly because as a result
of being the most competitive industry
in almost every industry the US had
faced great potential opportunities
through the lowering of tariffs and
through achieving free trade the United
States led a restructuring of the global
economy and so in in the late 1940s we
implemented what is known as the as the
virgin
program to liberalize essentially the
entire global economy so we established
the International Monetary Fund we
established the World Bank and what's
known as the GATT the general agreement
on tariffs and trade and those
institutions to govern a global economy
I still do the GATT has become the World
Trade Organization but those are the
fundamental organizations that have
overseen the revitalization of
globalization over the past 70 years
interestingly the establishment of that
system was initially created essentially
on the basis of of the widely accepted
neoclassical theory of International
Economics and under that theory it was
argued that countries would maximize
their welfare
by reducing their tariffs and by
concentrating on what they made best and
importing the rest now that system was
based on a number of assumptions one of
the assumptions was that there would be
no movement of technology or of people
between economies another assumption was
that exchange rates would be fixed and
and
not necessarily be the gold standard but
we had a system in which all global
currencies were pegged to the u.s.
dollar and the dollar acted as the
world's money as a kind of a substitute
a gold standard and the status of the
global economy in in a rough way
met the conditions of those assumptions
so trade and the in the light or a let's
say the 1950s for 1940s 1950s 1960s was
largely in commodities in which there
were very large markets and no single
producer had enough production to affect
the final price or the amount of total
global production we had the dollar as
as a kind of stable global currency with
a tide of gold and I would say between
let's say 1945 and 1972 we saw a free
trade system that operated roughly as it
would be expected to operate under the
reigning doctrines of of international
economic theory and we saw enormous
growth globally both globally and in the
United States in the US GDP per capita
nearly tripled in that time period this
was the Golden Age of the American
economy but
difficulties arose in the system as
other countries recovered as Germany
recovered Japan recovered and others
from the devastation of the war they
began to become competitive in a range
of manufacturing and technology
industries and many of them began to
operate their economies in ways that
were at odds with the assumptions of
international economic theory and at
odds with the intent of the of the
Bretton Woods organizations that had
been established in the late 1940s the
United States began to experience trade
deficits the US had been in a trade
surplus country since the mid 19th
century but after 1972 just began to
experience large and rising trade
deficits and so in response to a lot of
those developing imbalances and problems
President Nixon took the US economy off
of the took the dollar off of the tide
of gold John Conlee this the Texas
Secretary of Congress former Texas
governor famously combatted to a group
of Europeans he said the dollar is our
currency but you're a problem and what
he meant by that was that the dollar was
not going to be pegged to gold it was
gonna fall the value of the dollar will
be determined by market forces and the
dollar would float up or down according
to
how Marcus versus Bishop and the
immediate impact was that the dollar
devalued and many of the countries who
were competitors of the US and the
global market took a hit their exports
dropped and they were less competitive
than they had them before the dollar was
floating if I could pause just a minute
and
excuse me thank you now in this new
regime
let's look at the period between 1972
and about and let's say 2001 ah and this
is the period when the the when
globalization expanded dramatically but
so at the same time did concerns and
imbalances and and disruptions occur in
in in the global economy and so we still
increasing trade friction between the US
and a number of other countries but
particularly initially we had trade
frictions with Germany in the early
1970s as as German exports particularly
of automobiles and of Steel began to
make big inroads in the US markets but
then we particularly began to have
issues with Japan I know something about
these issues because in that period I
was counselor to the Secretary of
Commerce and I was the chief US
negotiator with Japan and I can tell you
that we it seemed like every every
morning I went to work I had a new issue
on my desk it would be steel there would
be semiconductors it would be
telecommunications equipment it would be
automobiles
it could be almonds I mean just one
industry after another complaining that
it was having a problem in Japan and the
problem always was the Japanese market
was very difficult if not impossible to
enter and the same time Japanese
companies were making big gaining large
market share in the US market and we the
u.s. trade negotiators would go to Japan
and we'd say guy you guys are unfair you
your you know our our markets are open
to you your marks eloped unless you're
unfair and if you don't stop being
unfair we're going to zap you we're
gonna impose countervailing duties and
and/or quotas on the number of
automobiles or other products that you
can sell to the US and Japanese response
was what are you talking about look you
know our products are high-quality your
you guys aren't aren't trying hard
enough
you you put the steering wheel on the
wrong side of the car you know your
quality stinks your your deliveries
always late your service is non-existent
you know you're not trying and so we get
this Mexican standoff well you know they
was we would say you Japanese are
cheating they would say no no you're
lazy you're not trying hard enough and
it went back and forth and eventually we
negotiated another maneuver in currency
so the the yen was revalued against the
dollar and that relieved some of the
pressure but we continue to have these
trade frictions and and then we got into
what I call the period the third period
of modern and globalization which we're
in now from about 2001 until the present
and 2001 is when China entered the World
Trade Organization when it entered the
World Trade Organization China had a
trade surplus with the United States of
about eighty billion dollars annually
and of course the US Congress had to
vote whether or not to accept China into
the World Trade Organization as a result
the US
the president and other US leaders had
to go up to the Congress and make their
argument and the argument was that
China's tariffs are higher than ours and
so if China is allowed into the world
trade organization it will have to make
more concessions than we do and so it's
tariffs will fall our tabs are already
low so they can't fall very much more
and so the result of this will be the
China will make disproportionate
concessions and US exports to China will
surge and this eighty billion trade
deficit will go away now you can all
look this up Charlene bar ships tea
mickey kantor other top officials of the
Clinton administration and then of the
Bush administration testified that
letting China into the World Trade
Organization was going to dramatically
cut this trade deficit with China well
today our trade deficit with China is
about 450 billion dollars nothing
happened in the way that the US
officials and in the way that the u.s.
economics community had analyzed the
trade between China and the US and that
brings us I think to a situation that
we're in today there is this and think
about my my hiker the hiker had a whole
different idea about condors and how
you're supposed to treat them then the
judge and the community at large they
weren't thinking the same way obviously
this is also true of the structure of
globalization today it's interesting if
you look at the very last page next to
last page of the Economist magazine in
every and every edition carries a table
of economic statistics one of those
statistics is the current account
deficit and surplus
and what's striking is that the Anglo
economies the Anglo countries England
Canada us Australia New Zealand you can
throw in India and South Africa all have
enormous trade deficits enormous current
account deficits whereas the Asian
countries Japan Korea Taiwan Singapore
China and in Europe Germany Norway
Switzerland the Netherlands all have
enormous trade sir current account
surpluses and that in my view reflects a
different concept of how globalization
and international markets work China for
example right now is pursuing a policy
in which the government will will take
States in some of the top high tech
Chinese companies companies like Alibaba
$0.10 WeChat the Chinese government is
going to turn them into state-owned or
partially state-owned enterprises China
or having already established the large
position of state-owned enterprises
Korea Japan other East Asian countries
continue to pursue quasi mercantilist
industrial industrial and trade policies
and so the bottom line is that we have
countries playing different games there
are different concepts of what free
trade is and of what globalization is if
how it should operate and there's a
clash between those concepts the Anglos
are kind of on one side and the rest of
the world on the other with various
players kind of in the middle well I
think that's the
a fundamental element of globalization
today with which trade negotiators and
economic policymakers are struggling and
so I think the questions for four
officials dealing with globalization is
what this globalization tastes like
thank you
[Applause]
good morning
I'm Jeff ferry and I'm with an
organization called the Coalition for a
prosperous America and we are a group of
manufacturers companies like Nucor steel
and hundreds of small manufacturers farm
organizations like the National Farmers
Union and labor unions like the AF of
l-cio all members of the CPA and we what
pulls us all together is we're all very
concerned about foreign trade and
restoring American prosperity and we
speak for four million Americans and I'd
like to speak to you a little bit this
morning about our view of globalization
and foreign trade you've already heard
Clyde and Dan talk about the continuity
of globalization and that the trend that
began hundreds of years ago and
continues I'd like to talk about some of
the differences between the
globalization that we know from the
previous period after the Second World
War that Dan talked about and
globalization today I'm sorry I'm going
to need to read from some of this so and
I'm also gonna have some slides very
soon it's gonna feel a bit like an
economics lecture and I apologize for
that
um okay so there are huge differences
between globalization now and
globalization in the immediate post-war
era back after 1945 countries like
Germany and Britain were advanced
nations that had been made poor by the
war once they recovered they adopted
similar attitudes to trade in real wages
that we have in the United States
in other words trade was fair and real
wages grew rapidly also the travel the
cost of travel and communication made it
economic to keep much more production
local today integration makes more
economic sense than local production
politicians and commentators often
overlook the crucial differences between
globalization or free trade in the 1950s
and 60s and today perhaps the best
example of that is the comment by
President Clinton in the early 1990s
about NAFTA when he said NAFTA would
turn Mexico into a nation of 120 million
consumers he was probably thinking of
how Germany had changed from a
bombed-out wasteland in nine
45 - a modern nation today where if you
go to Germany all you see are Mercedes
and BMWs angling for parkings places but
Mexico has not turned into a nation of
consumers far from it and I'd like to
talk about some of the downsides of
globalization and some of the economic
reasons why globalization has not
delivered for the US Mexico or many
other countries what it's what it does
what free trade delivered previously the
first thing I want to talk about is free
trade theory free trades become the
religion of mainstream us economists
they support it blindly in spite of the
facts and in spite of the internal
inconsistencies in their own arguments
I've lost count of the number of times
I've heard or read economists and others
declare the free trade between nations
will always lead to greater efficiency
lower prices and higher incomes for all
trading partners back in 1941 two
economists Wolfgang Stolper and Paul
Samuelson published a famous paper in
trade theory putting forward the famous
Stolper Samuelson theorem what this
theorem said was that if two nations
trade with each other trade could lead
to new prices that could actually reduce
the return to one factor and therefore
would reduce the level of income for
that factor and perhaps for that entire
nation to give you an example if Kenya
was in a trading zone where it was the
sole supplier of coffee beans and it
suddenly merged its trading zone with
another trading zone including Brazil
the result could be a drop in the price
of Kenyan coffee beans that would make
Kenyan coffee farmers worse off the
Stolper Samuelson theory goes further
and shows that Kenya's national income
could fall as a result of this merger of
trading areas a free trade agreement
this trade is kinda is usually called
emitter ating trade in economics but you
probably didn't hear that term if you
studied undergraduate economics because
the free trade religion tends to avoid
the mathematical proofs that show where
free trade can fall down another example
of the Stolper Samuelson theorem in
action
is think of a country with very high
wages for unskilled labor the United
States of America think of a country
with low wages for height for unskilled
labor Mexico
you put those two countries together the
large number of low paid unskilled
workers in Mexico causes a drop in the
pay rates of the unskilled workers in
the United States if there are enough
unskilled workers in the United States
it's not only they who will suffer but
the entire economy so in theory that
could be the result of the NAFTA
agreement that was signed in 1994 let's
keep that in mind and look at some
numbers in a moment ok I want to talk
about wages you actually don't even need
to go as far as Stolper Samuelson x'
case to understand how wages could
affect could be affected by a free trade
agreement or by globalization in fact
the whole point of globalized free trade
is to create a single competitive market
and dan talked about that competition
creates efficiency it does competition
also drives to a single price so whether
you're a bond trader in New York earning
half a million dollars a year before
free trade or before globalization or a
machinist in Indiana earning $40,000 a
year if you're suddenly competing with
hundreds of millions of workers in
Mexico Asia South America and elsewhere
you could see your wages go down due to
wage convergence everybody's wages comes
together in a gigantic global market
there's an old Irish joke about the
driver who stops on a country road in
Ireland and says to the IRA the old
Irish farmer walking down the road
excuse me I'm going to Cork can you tell
me how to get to Cork and the Irish
farmer stops for a second and thinks and
I went through the brogue because it's
been a long time since I've been to
Ireland but he says begorrah some if I
were going to Cork I wouldn't be
starting from here
and you might say that if you were going
to create a single globalized market you
might not want to start by being one of
the highest-paid nations in the world
with an 18 trillion dollar economy and
that's that summarized that expresses
some of the wage effects I want to talk
about you may know that according to US
Commerce Department figures median
household income in 2016 was the same
$59,000
that it was in 1999 in 17 years median
household income in the United States
did not progress at all the last time we
had that situation was in the Great
Depression now why did that happen um
let me move on to let me show you a
slide here um the US version of
globalization has actually been worse
than globalization as experienced in
other countries and I'm thinking mainly
of a country like Germany we are
unfortunate in that we have Mexico as a
neighbor to the south you can see from
this data that Mexican wage levels are
the worst performers in the OECD there
the red line at the bottom they have not
risen at all since NAFTA began in fact
they've dropped a little bit partly
because the peso fell but mainly because
of the nature of the Mexican economy it
is structured in a way that even though
industry has boomed that hasn't gone
through to workers
u.s. real wages have gone up a little
bit but the result is that US workers
are competing now with Mexican workers
the Mexican system is set up so as not
to allow real wages to rise therefore
what's going to happen a single
competitive market here's what's going
to happen in these three sectors you can
see the decline in u.s. real wages what
I've done is I've taken the wages of
production workers i've devalued them by
inflation since the peak year after 2000
2000 is in my view the beginning of the
era of globalization automotive vehicle
production workers wages have fallen by
27 percent since 2002
in real terms when adjusted for
inflation that is a staggering
decline in income other industries have
fallen less only 4% in computer and
electronics and smaller amounts in other
industries the automotive industry has
borne the brunt of the NAFTA policy of
multinationals and US corporations
shifting production to Mexico so when
you think about a 27% fall in real wages
it's no wonder that last November two
candidates Donald Trump and Bernie
Sanders got a lot of votes by saying hey
NAFTA is not working I want to just talk
for a moment about the politics of all
this a key element in globalization is
what I would call the mass delusion that
by ceding control over an economy to
multinational corporations we can
somehow do an end run around deep-seated
political and social problems in some
nations the experience of Mexico is a
good example NAFTA has come an enriched
the factory owners and the plutocrats in
Mexico as Lou Dobbs said one last night
one of the plutocrats is now a large
investor in the new york times good for
him
he knows how to make a lot of money the
experience of Mexico shows us that you
cannot change a political system through
this sort of economic reform too often
economists and politicians forget that
American economic prosperity is built on
the bedrock of a democratic system that
we established here in 1787 and
continues today in Mexico they are
unfortunately the heirs of a political
system developed in Spain that has a
huge deficiency in democracy
multinational corporations cannot fix
that only the Mexican people themselves
and the Mexican government can address
that but I digress let me turn to the
effect of globalization on employment
this slide shows the ten nations with
whom the US has its largest bilateral
trade deficits as of last year I'm going
to give Mexico a break and talk about
China for a moment according to
estimates from a Washington think tank
trade with China since the year 2000 has
resulted in the loss of 3.4 million US
jobs u.s. industries the
have lost hundreds of thousands of jobs
include toys furniture apparel footwear
and electronics it's becoming
commonplace now within the economics
profession to describe the effects of
the upsurge in China imports as the
China shock the term was invented by
Professor David otter at MIT and they've
produced a series of articles that show
the effects of the China shock they hit
mainly smaller towns and cities all
across America and in places like Texas
and the south and the industrial Midwest
the periods of employment can last as
long as ten years and even when people
get jobs after losing their jobs in
their original industry there's greater
job churn there's an increased incidence
of applying for federal disability
benefits increased incidents of people
dropping out of the labor force and most
tragic of all what they've noticed in
these communities statistically there's
a reduction in the number of marriages
that happen and it's documented that
women including women with children
choose not to get married in these
communities at a higher rate because the
men have an uncertain future of earning
and all that happened as a result of the
China shock now those of you who've
studied economics will recall that the
theory of comparative advantage tells us
that if another nation is more efficient
at producing and exporting certain Goods
than workers in the importing nation
will move into new industries leading to
higher total productivity and higher
national income there are two problems
with this economic theory the first is
that there's a transitional period
professor author showed that period
could be ten years if you have a ten
year transition you may never get to the
period where there's a new industry and
new growths all of those communities in
other words all the areas outside of the
two coastlines could suffer that's the
first problem the second problem is more
simple what if there are no new
industries what if we've pushed men and
women out of apparel toys electronics
steel automotive and machine tools and
there are no higher value industries
to go in to sound strange right sounds
counterintuitive it is the way that the
Asian countries that Clyde was referring
to that run trade surpluses think they
think there are industries that we
should have our people in because those
are growth industries and the other
industries don't matter if they're right
and we're wrong and we get the
industries that are left over we are a
slow growth nation have a look at this
slide you the red line on the from the
top is manufacturing employment it was
eight it was 18 to 20 million for most
of my childhood the 60 70s and 80s after
2000 it collapsed by five million and
today there are 12 million plus
manufacturing employees in the United
States the blue line shows employees at
food and drink places retail restaurants
and fast food places that line is
pushing 12 million most economists
expect in a couple of years we will have
more Americans working in food and drink
establishments than in manufacturing now
here's the problem look at the figures
below manufacturing as of August data
from the BLS average hourly earnings
were 26 dollars an hour average wheat
hourly average hours per week were 40
hours the average manufacturing worker
was earning $1,000 a week I'm sorry we
cut off some of the bottom of the slide
there but what the numbers tell us is
that in the food and drink industry the
average hourly earnings are just under
$14 an hour and the average hourly the
average hours per week are about 26
hours you do the math and the average
worker in that industry is earning 365
dollars a week so if you had a
manufacturing job you might have been
earning a thousand a week you went to
the food and drink business and now
you're earning 365 dollars a week and I
won't say anything about benefits
because I think everybody in this room
knows how the benefits situation works
so imagine if you're a single person
taking a 66% pay cut
now imagine if you've got kids and
you're trying to support kids on a 66%
pay cut and then economist tells you
free trade means that everybody moves
into a better more high productive job
well you know I think I know how I would
vote if an economist told me that and
I'm an economist okay and that let me
move on to talk about inequality uhm
globalization's led to increased
inequality and to my surprise Citibank
an investment bank just published a
study on inequality documenting that the
situation is bad they're very worried as
an investment bank with lots of rich
customers that inequality could lead to
populism which could lead to high taxes
on the rich so there and and there a
Great Wall Street institution they put
their cars on the table and they tell us
how deep the problem is and you can see
here that in the u.s. inequality has
jumped significantly as its jumped in
almost every country they looked at
here's another closer look at u.s.
inequality in the u.s. real GDP has
risen as as Dan said incomes gone up in
this country the problem is more and
more of our GDP is going on health
education and corporate profit so it's
not translating through the personal
income that's problem number one a sort
of structural problem in the economy
problem number two is income
distribution the top 20% of our
population has seen income rise 82%
since 1967 the second quintile has seen
a significant rise the other three
quintile sixty percent of the population
are roughly flat since 2000 and and down
in some cases so we've got a growing
inequality problem which is storing up
political problems for us um finally I
want to say something about economic
growth okay so um and Clyde referred to
this I think we compared your Anglo
countries to Asian countries in the long
run nothing is more important than the
rate of economic growth if income per
person rises by 3 percent
year then standards of living double in
a generation the American Dream is alive
and well and all is good but if income
per person rises by half a percent a
year as we've seen recently and on top
of that if we shift all of that growth
to the top twenty percent of the income
distribution then the other 80% is not
happy descent and hostility grow
politics takes on a nasty tone Americans
lose faith in our desire or our ability
to play a leading role in the world the
US has run trade deficits for 41 years
now there's no record anywhere in the
history of the world of a nation running
trade deficits consistently for 41 years
the effects of all those trade deficits
and the rising level of imports behind
them is to hollow out US industry and
rob us of the high-paying rising
productivity jobs in the best fastest
growing industries free traders like to
tell us that the trade deficit doesn't
matter because we're getting goods from
foreign nations at lower prices than we
ever could afford to produce for
ourselves and they're right about that
point free trade enables low prices but
remember the old saying you give a man a
fish you feed him for a day you teach a
man to fish you feed him for a lifetime
I was in North Carolina a few weeks ago
talking to people in the western part of
the state and I was talking about the
furniture industry and I mentioned in
the 1990s Walmart arrived cheap Chinese
furniture everybody went to Walmart and
said this is great the prices are great
you fast forward 20 years and what you
find is that in North Carolina all the
furniture factories are shut the main
streets are boarded up these people
don't have jobs when I put up the slide
and talked about how much you earn in a
fast-food restaurant their heads were
nodding they got the message
prices do matter I hear that all the
time but strong growing industries
matter more and industries for the
future matter not just to us because I'm
getting on a little bit they married to
my managed marry they math sorry
matter to my daughter and to the
children she's gonna have and here's the
proof this is the economic proof of what
Clyde referred to on the x-axis is the
level of trade surplus current account
surplus and the y-axis is the long-term
economic growth rate the successful
countries are in the upper right portion
of this graph and the and the less
successful countries like the United
States the United Kingdom are down there
towards the left with growth of under
one percent Singapore is way up at the
right Singapore has run a trade surplus
every single year since 1990 sometimes a
huge trade surplus Singapore has a
larger income per head than the United
States of America Singapore also has a
larger manufacturing sector as a share
of GDP than the United States is America
so don't think it's a financial set
center I used to work in the optical
networking industry my eyes were opened
when I went to Singapore and colleagues
of mine said oh there they're poaching
our executives all the time they are
aiming to be num a big player in optical
networking because it's crucial to the
future of the internet so you know what
I would say is that economics is that
economic growth depends on a sound trade
policy and we in this country are far
from having that if I can just conclude
with one last slide I don't want to
sound gloomy and I apologize if I have
sound gloomy sounded gloomy but I do
think the economics profession my
profession is changing and on this slide
there are quotes from several liberal
mainstream economists all from this year
who've all admitted that they were wrong
about trade one day maybe you'll be on
this slide dan let me just let me just
read right and I'm gonna read one quote
from Paul Krugman who won a Nobel Prize
to trade economics and for being a free
trader in the 1980s and 1990s and he
said earlier this year in a talk in New
York City the thing I really kicked
myself for missing is workers are a lot
less fungible and a lot less mobile and
a lot less able to shift jobs than we
had imagined or would like to imagine
when all the export-oriented workers in
some Midwestern town
have lost their jobs that matters the
effects are bigger so people are waking
up even economists are looking up from
their mathematical models and starting
to face reality now we need to get down
to the gritty hard work of developing a
post globalization economic strategy to
restore u.s. economic prosperity and
bring the American dream back to life I
believe it can be done thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right well thank you very much to
all of our panelists for your
presentations
we do want to take questions from the
audience however maybe we could start
with just a couple of minutes if any of
the panelists would like to respond to
any of the other panelists comments just
a couple of minutes and then we'll open
the floor for audience questions dan
Griswold
yes thank thank you Tim well I could
spend another half an hour responding to
everything I did did as Tim mentioned I
wrote a book when I was at the cato
institute called mad about trade i just
suggest you take a look at it because i
systematically address every every point
that's come up here but let me just
focus in on one or two jeff i'm pleased
that you mentioned singapore as your
model singapore is a totally free trade
country totally open they have virtually
no tariffs on on anything jeff said
there isn't a single country that's had
trade deficits for 40 years actually
there are a few australia being one of
them
australia has higher annual trade
deficits than we do they're also the
happy country that i don't think has had
us major recession in those 40 years
they're a successful country
neoclassical trade theories gotten
banged over the head check out Doug
Irwin's book against the tide an
intellectual history of free trade
you'll see that all the the
stopler-samuelson theorem is based on
some very limited kind of exotic
assumptions and most economists see it
as a textbook example but not having
much effect in the real world Cato
recently published the Cato Institute
where I used to work every year they do
an economic freedom of the world study
they measure economic freedom in a lot
of things including freedom to trade and
they find consistently that nations that
are open to trade open to the global
economy have higher incomes and achieve
higher rates of growth - two more things
quickly Mexico and nobody knows Mexico
in the United States better than the
people of Texas Mexico is not the same
country it was 30 years ago they have
in Mexico with unions and state-owned
enterprises nafta's been good for Mexico
they have a stable growing middle class
after 70 years of one-party rule Mexico
is a lively multiparty democracy I think
NAFTA has played a role in that and
finally about jobs and again I wrote a
whole chapter on this we're a service
economy the vast just about everybody in
this room makes your living in the
service economy you're not flipping
hamburgers most job growth is not only
in the service sector but in sectors
that have high wages business and
professional services finance health
care education the the choice isn't a
manufacturing job or flipping burgers
its educate ourselves and our children
to fill the jobs being created today and
tomorrow not looking back on some
nostalgic past that wasn't all that
great anyway I think thank you Dan
[Applause]
with that I think we'll open the floor
for questions
we have students again with microphones
please wait for the mic and we'll bring
it to you and you may ask your question
of any of the panelists or all of them
good morning I'm wondering if any of the
panelists have looked at the impact of
diversity versus a homogeneous
population on how easy it is for
countries to readjust and refocus as the
global economy has changed well I don't
think we've I haven't and I'm not aware
of any studies that have looked at the
issue of readjustment based on diversity
of population but I think that there are
differences and mentioned for example
Singapore I've spent a lot of time in
Singapore Singapore can adjust even more
easily to our economic difficulty than
the United States one reason of course
is because it's only four million people
it's not really a country it's a
city-state but another reason is because
the Singaporean government actively
intervenes in the economy in a variety
of ways so when when there's a downturn
the Singapore government calls in the
labor leaders and it says hey guys no
raises this year and it then becomes
very active in sending agents to the
United States to recruit new investment
so you know while it's true that
Singapore has low tariffs and rates high
on this on the scale that Dan mentioned
of economic freedom
fact is that the Singaporean government
intervenes in the economy in a variety
of ways that are at odds with with free
trade thinking but that seemed to work
for Singapore Singapore systematically
the Economic Development Board of
Singapore analyzes global economies and
global corporations and it approaches
companies that it thinks would be good
to have in Singapore all right and it
offers them tax benefits so you if you
come to Singapore we'll build the
infrastructure and no taxes for 25 years
utilities that have cost and so it
effectively subsidizes capital
investment and tries to attract
investment away from from other
countries to come to Singapore in a in
an aggressive and active way and that
makes it easier for them to adjust to
economic disruption the same is true of
a number of other countries and this
gets back to the point I was trying to
make that we have two different concepts
of globalization one concept of
globalization is epitomized by Singapore
for example apparently is for free trade
because there's no tariffs but Singapore
also manipulates its currency you know
when when it looks like the Singapore
trade surplus might fall Singapore
devalued its currency they intervened in
the market to devalue the currency so
this one concept of the globalization is
that the government is actively involved
in in dealing with currency policy
investment policy and so forth to assure
that transitions are made smoothly the
other concept of globalization
epitomized by as I said the Anglo
countries is that the
hands off and faith that the market will
adjust everything smoothly there's a
clash between those two concepts of
globalization that clash has been
becoming more intense over the past 40
years and because of the impact of China
it has it's a clash that's reaching far
beyond economics and then to national
security policy
okay year after year I teach economics
and hundreds of students are taking my
classes I wonder since they're running
trade deficits against me should they
start students first program and imposed
tariffs on me yeah it's it's the the
personal example I run a huge trade
deficit with the grocery store they they
never asked me to come and give a
lecture on free trade there but somehow
the dollars work around look we could
talk a lot about the trade deficit the
flip side of the trade deficit is a
capital surplus that's why I mentioned
early on half a million Texans working
for foreign owned companies where where
does Samsung and Toyota get the dollars
to invest in those factories in Texas
and around the country more than six
million Americans working for foreign
owned affiliates two million of them in
manufacturing they get it by selling
into our market the dollars command but
what four trillion dollars flow out of
the United States each year to buy goods
and services and invest abroad virtually
every one of those four trillion dollars
flows back pretty quickly to buy our
goods and services and also to invest in
the United States so we've got problems
in this country but they're not going to
be solved by raising barriers to trade
and investment can I can I provide a
slightly different perspective on the
trade deficit we as a nation are running
a five hundred billion dollar a year
trade deficit that means we're borrowing
five hundred billion dollars from
foreigners every year to support our
consumption habits it might not be so
bad if we were investing that five
hundred billion dollars in future
productive capacity but we're not with
the feds policy of low interest rates
we're investing it in all the things you
hear about the financial sector health
care things that may be good in
themselves but can't pay for themselves
what has happened to every Empire in the
past is they borrow a lot of money and
at some point the rest of the world says
we no longer want to lend you any money
and then there's an economic crisis
and then the Empire ends I studied
economics in Britain the tale of the
decline of the British Empire is exactly
that and it's not that long ago I have
no doubt that that will happen to the
United States if we turn 40 years of
trade deficits into 60 years 80 years
and a hundred years and only the other
day I read in the newspaper that the
Chinese government is now negotiating
with the Saudis about paying their oil
bills in yuan not in dollars anymore it
hasn't happened yet but it will happen
think about that if the entire oil
market moves from the US dollar to the
Chinese yuan what that means for demand
for the dollar goes down what that means
for demand for US Treasury bonds goes
down and what that means for the
American Century I think you can all
conclude
[Applause]
but just have one comment with just to
the professor it's true that your
students run a trade deficit with you
and and actually those students are you
know they're impoverished if if I had to
live off of the arrangement they
wouldn't be your students but their
parents or somebody is is paying the
bill and so they're able to withstand
that deficit but if you know if if you
were actually operating on a
straight-out
economic basis the students wouldn't be
there I think we have one more question
time for one more
yeah this is Hasan's I am from austin
peay from Clarksville Tennessee The
Economist's without economic backgrounds
they are just actors and I like today's
versus yesterday's the u.s. is based on
the US is based on the corporate
structure of it is based on a
stockholder and a stockholders are the
owners other countries they have
different kinds of stakeholders Japan
Germany they have bondholders and others
as a stakeholder as consumers and even
the government in the United States
there are some service organizations
that are turning into private
enterprises hospitals for examples they
are now owned by stockholders for those
three economists that are on the panel I
would like to see their point of view
with regard to ownership for healthcare
industry using the form of corporate
America and also forgetting about the
consumers side and also the government
who sometimes look at economics as a
sideshow and look at only politics in
the state of really economics that based
on theory and also practice successful
thank you
well let me take a cracker I think that
the that's an excellent point that the
questioner has made because and it goes
to the heart of the issue of I'm trying
to raise here today which is the form of
globalization and the clash between
forms of globalization and he's
completely right the stakeholders in
various economies are quite different
he mentioned Germany in Germany
corporations have a supervisor they have
two boards a supervisory board and a
management board the management board is
the board of directors consisting of the
chief officers of the corporation the
supervisory board is the oversight board
which includes the some of the office of
the corporation but it also includes the
labor unions importantly and it includes
outside players and you know the result
has been that whereas in the u.s. the
focus of corporations is very strongly
on on making money now and very strongly
on the stock price and the financial
aspects of the business because the
nature of its board the German
corporation takes a longer-term broader
societal view of how it should be acting
and how it should be investing if you go
to a country like China I mentioned that
the Chinese Communist Party I mean this
is not even the government but the party
is now pursuing a policy that that party
members need to be on the in the
governing bodies of the corporations and
of course we know that many countries
China leading but many other countries
have state-owned enterprises that's a
different stakeholder and that
stakeholder views trade and investment
in a strategic way
and in a broad way rather than in an
administrative efficiency way which is
which characterizes the theory of
American business and trade and so yes
the state the nature of the stakeholder
is a very critical factor
thanks for bringing up that question let
me put in a good word for the
anglo-saxon model I think it's held up
pretty well the shareholder Corporation
has served Western civilization pretty
well for 400 years or so I think if you
look at those anglo-saxon nations Great
Britain the United States New Zealand
Australia we remain among the freest
most prosperous nations in the world the
rest of the world has been moving
towards our model I remember back in the
1980s when people were warning us about
the Japanese model and they were going
to steamroll us well they did and I
think a lot of the hand wringing about
China and other countries today is
equally mistaken mark my words the the
China shock was a one-time seven or
eight year transition China's now
becoming more of a normal country
they're running into their own
demographic headwinds China's going to
face some of the same problems Japan had
I'll just end with this the last 30
years we've had an experiment the last
hundred years central planning
government central direction versus the
free market the free market one
let's not imitate the people who lost
[Applause]
finally some concluding comments quick
comment I certainly don't support
central planning I do however support a
model like we've spoken about Singapore
where the government sets the terms and
says trade surpluses and growth
industries matter now you the free
market sector get on with it as far as
shareholder democracy and shareholders
I do support shareholder democracy
absolutely and the shareholding system
but we do have to be aware that there's
more and more pressure on corporations
to be shorter and shorter term and China
is gaining on us quickly and when we
look at for instance the steel industry
China is now more than 50 percent of
world's steel production there are key
elements in our military I'm talking
about ships and planes and vehicles
where the components cannot be
manufactured here then we need to import
them and if you take a long term view it
is possible there will be a war again
somewhere someday and the government and
the private sector need to be aware of
that and take a long term view with
China we have an adversary in the world
that's a different kind of nation from
previous adversaries I'll just mention a
joke some of you may know Deng Chao ping
who basically invented the current
Chinese system which is capitalism in
communist clothes was asked once back in
the 1990s whether he thought the French
Revolution was a success he thought for
a moment and his answer was it's a
little too soon to tell I think that
expresses how the Chinese view the
challenge of the 21st century and I
think it's incumbent upon us to take
that kind of view as well thank you Jeff
please join me in thanking our panel
[Applause]